[Music]
for something
you
sit down let's go man let's go how we do
it that's how we do it right here on
twitch.tv slash retro raconteur ladies
and gentlemen we don't always win we
don't always get the victory Royale but
what we do is we have fun
[Music]
are you keep oh my goodness this little
guy
just look at the pretty little face my
gosh I don't like this I do not like
like it
what
[Music]
good night sir
goodnight thank you
just go ahead get behind him
no no no no
[Music]
it's the back air
let's go
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh my
[Music]
let's go
there is baby let's go
thanks for checking out the stream
tonight come on guys it's gotta be hit
that's gotta be it
let's go dude let's go
three million global smush hole all
summons is there something's gonna kill
me at the end there is isn't there it's
going for the close up it's only fitting
it's only it's only fitting that it
should end this way
[Music]